we're gonna get this underway and we're
gonna have fun with it that's a the
rules you have to have fun with it right
because when you're in space you got to
have fun or else you just start
screaming about the inexhaustible
darkness that surrounds you the
impenetrable crushing weight of
nothingness weighing down on your soul
the only thing around you is this
screams that fill up your own head
because no one will ever hear you or
care the universe is just an uncaring
endless box of torment built to design
to hate itself everyone who ever existed
and ever was is only doomed a destiny to
die alone sad always pondering the
endlessness of existence and yet the
futility that is life there's nothing
left for us the universe is a big empty
tomb we're all gonna die a horrible
horrible death and then we're going to
play a video game so this is space oh I
know oh it's real pretty I just you wait
there we go there's the Sun everyone's
blind now alright science lesson number
one the big glowing ball of fire that go
across sky big ball fire that Sun Sun be
bright ball fire make cavemen inside go
girl but not bad good very good
big ball fire we call Sun God Sun God
you pray you pray to Sun God it gives
you food and sexy wife if you pray hard
enough you get good mate you get good
food and then you get to have good good
time make sense uh everyone pray to Sun
God
all right moving on this is where our
everybody know you're alright choir
you know the darkness you feel inside
heart that choir when you pray to
sadness inside you pray do choir what
the [ __ ] is good
why or even know what was there a little
wait what the hell did I just see what
is this what is it 2004 Oh what are
these we're so far away oh my god
okay well there's Pluto Oh quiet out
farther than Pluto anyway here's Pluto
Oh spending a little faster right Pluto
okay so this is universe sandbox so this
game that allows you to explore all of
the elements of the universe and we're
gonna start by blowing up the Sun kaboom
to fast thereby go out there everybody
gone oh-oh Jupe Jupe I'm sorry alright
okay that way to Chicago the entire
sources of blows up in Chicago Chicago
Chicago
I pause time Chicago's are shaken
Chicago Chicago Chicago is strong hey
Natalie you're not lying about that [ __ ]
Chicago is very strong
you're real jiggly okay so wait where's
quiet Claire no cops cop please cop is
going whoa Golf is a fire ball let's
start this over something when I know
her if eclis wrong all right so ah I'm
gonna go for just I want the solar
system again or is this a normal solar
system so this is now in real time let's
do not the real time one cuz the real
time is stupid
whoa there's quiet air sadness I know
what are you where'd you come from
look at that look how pretty that is
ain't that pretty
pretty okay let's go back to the Sun
okay you remember Sun right
you remember Sun everybody remember Sun
I say big fireball in sky man what the
[ __ ] someone flying by Sirius was that
you know goodbye
who mercury come back we'll get you get
your mercury so what uh what I'm gonna
do today is play around until I get
bored let's do a little bit of Education
so I've taught you quite a bit about the
Sun big fire God in sky fire God bring
rain if you pray hard enough along with
hawa it rain hot wives and husbands once
you pray hard enough to Sun God in sky
make sense all right but now let's let's
carry a few thought experiments all
right so the Sun is big right but it's
not that big because I can show you
something even bigger and it sounds like
a euphemism but hang on so gooey Scootie
here is um a star police scooty is this
big compared to our entire solar system
right compared to our tire solar system
who eise Kui is this big and if I were
to pop it down it would encompass
everything including the Sun and the
entire orbit of Jupiter so let's pop
down ooh a scooty there there's
ooey-gooey what who is scooter why are
you moving
where are you going who is goody where
are you going
what oh hey scooty
where's it where are you going I didn't
put you with any moment
okay whatever okay who is Kui I don't
know why let's just get rid of okay I
gotta restart this no that's not what I
expected to happen everybody hold on
your heads
okay so Oh ace cooties that big right so
stars right stars are just measured
pretty much by their mass so this one's
one Sun cuz it's the Sun but it's one
son
so one Sun we can change it up in its
size so let's make this bad boy let's
make this two suns and now as the mass
of two suns
oh whoa okay so that's weird I don't
know why it says Sun Nova remnant but it
didn't go Nova so what happened is all
of the objects orbiting it suddenly fell
in a not quite circular orbit you can
even see the little bits of the asteroid
belt coming in here pretty cool right
now this is just because the Sun doubled
in size so the gravity well became twice
as steep if you know what I mean
so everything spirals off in cool ways
like this alright we're going up to
three suns okay now everything cut in
even smaller everything's going deeper
that's fine let's go up to five sons
there it goes
it's like everything's spinning down the
drain see as it gets more massive it not
only gets bigger but just like
everything just spins around it faster
because it kind of has to to keep up its
orbit
things how they go faster down there
we're gonna go all the way up to ten
Suns boom
ooh dass and I spin so mercury should
probably be close enough that it's gonna
start bleeding off part of its matter no
not yet it's getting hot though it's
real hot we're gonna go up to 20 this
might actually suck in mercury 20
there we are close up it's fireball okay
Mercury's dunzo Oh Mercury's so dunzo
all right so Mercury's done for Venus is
toasty toasty
oh man I'm surprised none of these have
hit each other earth how's earth doing I
didn't even check in on Earth how are we
doing ooh-whoo not not good not as good
as you might think and I don't think
very good ah okay so Chicago's probably
doing fun but we're not let's go even
bigger let's make this bad boy a
whopping 30 suns and we'll do it right
there gotcha let's go back up to like
six hours a second whoo Venus split up
Venus couldn't handle the pressure
earth is still going strong though Venus
is dunzo Venus is extremely done though
okay by Feeny
Oh oops you're coming in to say hello
even though Jupiter was going over there
I'm surprised Mercury's still there that
should that's not right oh it's slowed
down I don't know why are we're going up
to 50 this might swallow up everything
we know okay 50
it's now so big
mercury is scraping along its atmosphere
I don't even know how Mercury's still
even intact
it should not be come though it is
coming so close to the Sun I don't
understand why it's not just absolutely
dead what is iris iris where did you
come from iris what the hell where did
IRA who's iris how many things are in
this solar system I don't even know uh
earth oh no no earth no no no where's
your [ __ ] Oh oh jeez hmm
I think that'll buff out oh yeah I'm
pretty sure that they'll buff out I'll
probably buff out we're going up to a
Hondo all right Hondo the Sun is now
very big it's what earth is gone well
[ __ ] okay Mars all on you baby wait okay
well let's get a close look at this one
all right baby you got a Mars II baby
all right Mars how you doing Oh God
where my gum I guess we're looking at
Juneau now all right Mars you baby look
you me do you have a tail all right it's
fine
you me baby here we go or on Sun
approach who is gonna be fun and poor
Mars all right there buddy
you're right all right you survived one
I'm sure you'll survive another this is
boring let's get let's get uh let's make
it 500 there we go now we're talking now
or docking Oh Mars hold on hold on Mars
you can do it all right I don't know
what fear is
Oh
[Music]
I meant to give a pep talk to Mars
before it it's bad
I guess Mars I'm gonna get that chance
huh
Jupiter is you gonna make it Oh Jupiter
don't look like it gonna make it but
maybe maybe you never know with the Jupe
I listen Juby you got this I don't know
I fear Hanser in the middle of you but
Jupe you got this look that son is a
[ __ ] a pushover even you can punch that
son right in the face and you should
because you feel good about it right
okay all right listen Jupe all right
listen here you go Jew but here's your
chance there's your shot at glory
all right Juba Depot buddy all right boo
buddy Scooby you're gonna get on you're
gonna get out there and you're gonna
you're gonna get him all right you're
already punching him with a oh wait okay
Jupe poopy all right listen listen
listen Jupiter wasn't you got this that
son pushover just to go I don't know it
cuz you pooped your pants oh oh oh you
got some acne there but it's okay I
think oh good all right so Jupe poopy
did pretty good
all right now let's stop playing around
let's make this thing 5,000 it's now
five thousand times its normal mass well
that's boring let's make its age like
500 billion oh it's going in jo p poopy
listen you got this jo p po p jo p ooh
okay
oh no Meah is palace Aries Vesta I don't
know a and these are I let's stop let's
stop [ __ ] around here let's go
[Music]
whoa too big um too big too big oops
I am too big
it's not a black hole what are you
talking about it's fine Bluto
Bluto blew it all is in Bluto listen how
you doing Bluto
all right listen all right you got the
eye of the tiger II hear
all right blue T blue T baby blue T baby
listen that that son pushover blue T you
got this it's your time to shine your
toy you know what in fact actually mercy
killed Pluto before it actually gets to
be too far listen this is for your own
good Pluto earth goodbye goodbye oh this
way here we go I missed you by that much
whoosh there we go where's Pluto Pluto
go
did you already hit Pluto what no what
weirdo
what you do with Pluto oh oh
all right well Pluto is done whoa nice
butthole all right so that's a weird eye
in the middle of os Uranus as a butthole
that's that's oddly fitting okay so you
see how that that that this real big you
see okay it's got the mass of 500
million suns let's make that five
billion just because I want to okay five
billion way bigger right okay everything
else has now been swallowed up it's
inside the black hole or whatever if it
was a black hole how do I change my
background let me change my background
let's go just stars nad Milky Way dark
and they'll go away bright brighter
nebula green wow that's got a pretty
Skyrim II wanna be a purple there's
purple red red cyan solid black solid
gray solid white that's awful
space blue oh that's nice I like that
cuz that gives a little more texture
behind everything space blue green and
yellow space brown perfect poop space
mist well that's kind of what's the
difference between that and space blue
okay I like space mist yeah that's good
stuff maybe yeah space mist okay good
wait what else can I change
hang on I'm too busy all right that'll
be good enough whatever it's probably
not as good as default but I don't know
I don't care I like it okay so you see
this thing right all right I'm gonna see
what happens when I blow up a black hole
because I honestly don't know
some awfully dramatic music for what
appears to be nothing happening
wait there's suddenly like tons and tons
of these son Nova fragments coming out
of nowhere what did it do anything did
it blow up did it blow up oh ho
I've never seen that before well it most
certainly hasn't
[Music]
okay that's weird okay we somehow blew
up a black hole I'm not sure how and I
was a little bizarre and I got try that
again and its second here okay all right
black hole pretty big boy not as big as
our previous big it's gone well there it
is
oh no it's tiny by comparison it is tiny
okay well this is a Wimpy baby size
black hole let make it even bigger even
bigger to the 20th huge even okay this
is huge real big but there's nothing
else to scale to put it by so let's put
a galaxy next to it by scale our
pinwheel galaxy right there Oh big okay
so that's the pinwheel galaxy and here's
our black hole so I want to make this
even bigger
oh it nevermind it's way bigger than the
Milky Way itself where did I put that
galaxy okay now it's real big now it's
Eve that's the maximum in that it could
possibly be it is now as big as it could
ever physically be where did that galaxy
go did this black hole swallow that
galaxy cuz that's an interesting
conundrum okay we're gonna blow this
thing up again this is now the biggest
black hole that you could possibly make
in the entire game let's see what
happens
[Music]
and it just
and that's it hey just go poof it's just
tiny poof and then it go bye-bye
all right well that's that's
anticlimactic Milky Way right dere wait
where'd it go
okay I think I I think I've really
royally borked
this entire game because it doesn't seem
to be working anymore what is that
where do we go oh can I blow you up and
blow up a galaxy I blow this up oh I
shouldn't have done that
Oh
[Music]
what's going on here okay I don't know
what this is definitely not supposed to
happen okay oh all right let's just
reset this because this is now gotten
beyond ridiculous
good old solar system okay so now let's
punish earth specifically so earth is a
real good place right real nice
everybody loves Earth right okay now
imagine and just imagine what if earth
was not okay right
you know like can you imagine that like
if Kepler Kepler Kepler Kepler oh if
Kepler was warbling oh hi Kepler Oh
ah [ __ ] okay well they're there when
earth okay listen about another Kepler
Oh
about more chem more there's another one
and another one and another one and
another one
how about another one another more more
MORE too many not enough another one or
another another okay all right here we
go all more copies kept lures okay cool
all right kept lure kept lure kept lure
alright there we go okay keep Kaplan
kappa lure kept lure kept Laura kept
lure Kepler lure Kepler
okay all right Kepler okay where to mass
to mass to mass boom hats to mass to
mass to mass wools look at him spin
dough mass tome ass oh [ __ ]
to mass boom ass comb ass to mass that's
its name it's to mass okay which one's
the main one is this a man 1 this is to
mass or to mask it back beef get your
ass back here to mass Oh
Tobi's kept Kepler her Easter Kepler did
you survive all that Kepler
oh the rampage of to mass never ends
Kepler how did you survive that I don't
even know I mean you're not gonna I'm
gonna make sure you don't but you know
how these tiny little baby plants God to
a mass tome toe mass all right to mass
listen here
for a second there I thought the
Sephiroth battle music just kicked up
just like Sephiroth comes in here blows
up the Sun he goes [ __ ]
I'm sorry okay let's try this again
Ganymede tiny tiny Ganymede okay listen
Ganymede can actually probably orbit in
a relatively nice way if it wasn't
forced into this situation where it's
not doing that you know what I mean
our Ganymede okay now all of you there
are struggling to survive but I'm about
to put a kibosh in that idea kaboom
Wow okay way back to the whatever the
hell we were doing okay so all the
Ganymede's you go blow up blow up blow
blow blow blow blow blow blow blow blow
I said blow Mars you're good you're next
you're next on the chopping block okay
Mars
everybody knows Mars the shining beacon
of love in the universe right okay
so imagine if how about what if we do a
bowling ball at the speed of light okay
there's the bowling ball what bowling
balls gone okay here's the bowling ball
go Shoom we're going what's a bowling
ball gonna do shot at light speed to
Mars Dan three two one
huh do anything they'd do anything it
did nothing there's going sofa I am
launching these but it's just going so
fast I can't see it new horizon no Tesla
Roadster no Great Pyramid there that had
an impact I feel like the others would
too
okay so that worked rival spacecraft
whoa that's not where I threw it but
okay
please box nothing nothing nothing
Saturn why are you flashing over there
right there you see that what is it
flashing hoots good someone's
communicating come on Saturn
who's there Kepler oh you were
communicating
oh well beer you're welcome alright see
ya anyway good bye bye Saturn Mars
where's Mars
have I seen Mars why's Mars running
there's Mars okay there we go so you
guys know Mars right you remember Mars
I think everybody does so what if
instead of that we threw an asteroid at
the speed of light oh okay that that's
that's something okay that's what they
would call a lot of damaged parts of
that hurt what about Pluto at the speed
of light curve ball well let's see how
fast I can get this bad boy to spin I
keep going keep going keep going let's
get some oh come on there no okay I
always got to hit in the direction then
it's spinning there's quite a spin on
this bad boy was a rotational speed on
that one I have no idea it's broche lobe
radius is 1.7 million kilometers and
rising what is it what is that what's
the Roche lobe radius hang on
oh it's the region around the star in a
binary system within the orbiting
materials gravitationally bound to that
star so I don't know what it means cool
to plant it down
I'm gonna do that but he expect me to do
that I can't do that it's not within my
power do you think a comet will do it no
that didn't do it a lot more comets No
okay oddly enough that didn't seem to do
it Eris no make make no okay she seems
to be going faster it's not any cooler I
don't know why water okay alright water
it's now a hundred percent water uh it's
not any cooler guys you might have been
wrong about it it's very uh not cool how
about if I give it some material water
here we go I'm gonna shoot some water at
it ah it's like a sprinkler here we go
now we got it you're gonna cool right
down there buddy boo don't worry about
it let me worry about it it doesn't seem
to be helping much oh it hasn't even
reached it yet oh I'm sorry
there goes now it's reaching it
quenching the thirst of it right here we
go oh now that's quenched oh now that's
quench something good oh no that's real
quench
well that's quench tastic oh that's so
quenched
I might even be quenched all right let's
uh some more can I get more please can
we have it faster I mean I can't be
waiting around forever for it oh here we
go now oh yeah now that's a Quan Chi oh
oh this is real quench Abel okay a nice
spiral of Quan Chi a you lazy water
bastards does seem to be working okay
maybe I need more particles alright let
me try this I'm gonna throw a thousand
Jupiter's worth of water at Mars here we
go oh that's gonna take forever to reach
ok whatever it's gonna hit this is a
thousand Jupiter's of water ah
[Laughter]
[Music]
what happened to my background no it was
all right that didn't work let's blow
that up oh it's still spinning
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay Mars not do so good but you know
hey that's alright where's Venus Venus
come on over there how did we get that
far out of the system by the way I don't
know just me hitting it with so many
things I'd eventually just push it so
far away you seem to be outlets uh I
know there's a way to reset its orbits
Auto orbit BAM done alright rotational
period is gonna be one day okay one day
one day who gonna be 0.5 day
woohoo alright I know Venus wanted to be
just a little more toasty six-hour
rotational period alright how about it
to our rotational
[Music]
okay we're just gonna Oh everybody look
away for a second just look away just
look away just look like Venus Venus I
forgot you're going the speed of light
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I launched ah [ __ ] okay
[ __ ] mercury buddy mercury
listen mercury listen don't worry about
don't worry about what the other just
just don't worry okay you seem worried
for some odd reason mercury listen all
those other planets were just dumb right
you're not dumb you're smart right all
right mercury if there's one thing I've
heard about you
mercury is that you want some moons so
here's one moon - here's if I could just
know not launch okay not launch we're
gonna orbit the moon is gonna orbit you
okay well there's got to be a tight
orbit or you're gonna lose it to the Sun
so you got to really hold on tight to
this one okay hold on tight okay and you
want one more hold on tight to that moon
can have up moon how about a moon for
the moon gonna have a nice moon moon
there we go Moon Moon for the moon you
get a moon - moon
moon moon moon moon know that moon can't
stay that's that's a bad moon okay
so mercury has moons which mercury has
always wanted moons I know this I've
heard this and it's gonna be fine [ __ ]
[ __ ] anyway enough about that that's
stupid and dumb let's where did
everything else in the universe go or
the solar system go where Jupiter go why
see Jupiter over here
Jupiter you trying to run away from me
are you going towards wait what's it
going towards are you going venus is
still going off that way where are you
going are to mass how are you doing how
are you doing - mass all right listen to
mass I may not have been very nice to
you but I'm gonna give you I'll give you
another gas giant here two-ton kurrus
get yep
ton cursed dekap tun chorus dekap DD the
foie the toast egg door yeah well that's
dumb what if I launch him at you is that
even hitting you is this even hitting
you is this hitting you how do I know
that this is hitting you well it seems
to be hitting him I think oh we are cuz
we're moving that's how we got moved out
cuz I you hit him Oh cuz I punched him
oh that's real there's real fast and far
away how am I going so fast and let's go
faster how fast can we go we're going up
to a moment of max speed whatever the
max speed is I'm hitting it oh okay
we're now going three point three four
times 10 to the 14th the speed of light
huh
I can't even focus on this thing took to
mass you okay there buddy to mass 2 -
Matt OH -
boom dome ass computers time to scaling
seems to be jumping real far too to me
you you're breaking all senses of logic
a rotational period let's make it point
oooo 1 so now it's spinning super fast -
can i zoom in on oh [ __ ]
Oh where's to mass ok err its to miss ok
to mass trying to land on to mass - [ __ ]
oh god oh god
oh I apparently I've landed on to mess
but it's so broken the laws of physics
at this point that I don't think there's
any way that it could possibly actually
not just be awful ok zooming out again
woof all right you know what I'm just
gonna let that go Oh oh my god I'm
zooming in there we are that's how far
away we were
where's to mass to mass there's do a
mass oh god oh god look at everything
else it's struggling just to calculate
the speed of to mass oh god oh god
all positional accuracy has gone it is -
alright I think we broke it okay we
figured out what broke it so let's go
out of here all plants almonds Saturn is
this oh my god
Saturn is dripping with moons God's at a
wall you greedy [ __ ] look at you
where's Dino Jupiter oh my god look I
know Jupiter has tons of oh my god okay
Jupiter you big [ __ ] show-off
Oh God Jupe oh I'm jus petite OOP etre
oh I'm jus / - pa'dar oh look at me mr.
big shot with all my moons even Earth
has more than one moon technically if
you're gonna buy that doesn't done earth
have more than one moon okay nevermind
I'm just a [ __ ] idiot I do I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
only one moon here okay nevermind Mars
you and your two
moons to piece-of-shit Dinko moons
stupid idiot thanks game oh no moans no
moans no moons really that's stupid
mercury no moons odds Dom Pluto I bet
Pluto's got new moon moons
Pluto's not even here what kind of solar
system is this okay what am I doing here
what was I supposed to be doing I had a
reason for pulling this up with the
moons but I can't remember what it is
force force equivalent to fourteen point
six three well that's boring the force
equivalent to a galaxy would that do
what the [ __ ]
Jupiter II Jupiter II what's Jupiter II
what what what the [ __ ] we just wait no
we were just zoomed into whoa wait wait
no oh oh oh we lose them the Sun Oh
Jupiter II jettison I guess that's what
force would do huh okay let's push it
back we gotta push it back guys come on
go back home are you going you going
home how are you going home I don't know
are you I don't know what this
what the [ __ ] is this rave show doing
today what is it doing is it doing um
okay let's just just blow this up for
now okay and it's gone I guess that's
all there is to that
alright see ya let's go back to Jupiter
II I want to see what this does
okay we're gonna go super slow cuz I
don't know what this is doing this for
sing so we're just gonna go here we're
gonna force this and go boink did that
do anything it's not doing nothing it's
doing nothing it's doing a whole lot of
nothing
what's it doing what's it doing wait a
shot met is straight wait oh it is doing
something wait wait no it's wait how
when did we do something well you
thought I well I thought I would have
seen that and why is it was it weird huh
what does it do it what okay let's go up
to a whopping 10 milliseconds a second
okay
alright bye they're all going love
Jupiter blob Jupiter you know actually
pulled up put a black hole at all this
just kibosh this is it goodbye
Right see ya you're all going in and
then I'm gonna blow up the black hole no
thank you
gah boom alright so that's done what
about Uranus what about Uranus ok Uranus
I'm gonna launch some stuff into this
butthole here and watch a bunch of moon
gypped duped duped is coming for that
moon baby duped is coming coming
straight for that butthole Oh what don't
be shy what what the hell's happening
but the butthole moved can you imagine
if you're looking up in the sky and then
you're and it's just like blinks and
then moved away it blow it up alright
enough of that let's get back to the
normal solar system planet 9 in our
solar system what does that mean Pluto
alright so I'm gonna do something I'm
gonna launch a black hole at the solar
system here there right there Darris you
go nevermind oh [ __ ] oh okay well that
that went that one different than I
thought it would we're gonna we're gonna
get off the uh we're gonna get off the
human scale what the [ __ ] dice dice
these are some really flat these aren't
dice oh they are they're just Oh are the
oh oh I see
oh let's blow it up kaboom kaboom boom
boom bam boo boom boom clap boop boop
boo boo P and Boop oh that's cool I
didn't even think about that orbiting a
bowling ball
whoa that's so cool that's cool we do
something else I wanted to do let me I
want to see something about a son you
know I want to see what happens if our
son because they said that you could age
it so let's let's age this thing
immensely let's go let's go like fifty
thousand years a second well maybe this
isn't even nearly enough yeah we need to
go way faster let's go five hundred
thousand years a second it's still too
slow let's go fifty million not still
too slow Billy in a second there it goes
look that bad boys getting big all
getting big and beefy whoo oh that was
it that was it that was it that was it
that was it that's all you're gonna do
uh-uh okay hang on wait hang on wait
yeah no I don't want to edit it no I
don't want to edit it delete it okay hey
hang on hang on I'm gonna add this big
boy who is scooty we're gonna age it
you're gonna get all old and wrinkly now
eventually I think you're gonna go
kaboom ain't ya
maybe no Denebola Denebola
wait it did go Nova Mar thiis why are
these just what's happening what the
heck what what what did serious B what
the Frick Canis Majoris what is
happening why Oh God Oh No Oh
I think we're starting to disappear into
the horizon of forever yep okay we've
frozen the whole game is crashed oh I
don't know what we were doing but we did
something okay I'm gonna go out of this
and we're going to go into the Galactic
scale not necessarily the normal scale
we're gonna go into the galactic scale
and wait many stars whoo
oh that's cool oh that's cool oh look at
that go Oh bye wolf where you go wolfy
wolfy oh whoa rave show aside we're
gonna go on to stress test oh hell yeah
oh oh oh okay let's do the thousand
plans first let's go that one we're a
stress test this bad boy oh to stress my
computer can't handle two struts -
stress - stress okay uh hmm Oh to stress
okay to stress - OH
to stress okay let's just try let's try
five thousand moons that's probably less
stress
I don't know why it's not going there I
think I might have to force quit out of
this because I think it's just broken
yeah probably I'm gonna force quit out
of this goodbye
[Music]